[Music]
[Music]
you got your prospective
[Music]
1:37 dinner all-star he rocked filming
[Music]
bored easily my setup so I literally
just left our roommate just a walk to
get action that's Louie we'll just have
[Music]
variance if you do that as a 25 year old
what he feels in his heart and brain at
33 what I feel at 43 and when he feels
at 50 here's the punchline we all feel
exactly the same if you do that you're
gonna live your whole life over again
and you'll be his age and you knew that
he basically has the same fire right
here and right here if I can get every
25 year old to know that they're not
even they're not even the dressing room
putting on their shorts for the game yet
and they think they're done they're like
oh [ __ ] I didn't figure it out yet right
you know what clue said to me the other
night he said if you know somebody and
you see them do something bad to
somebody else it's inevitable that
they'll do to you literally I'm being
serious with you I'm bringing up now
I've been thinking about I've thought
about it multiple times every day since
I saw you guys I know it but I don't
know why the way you said it click with
me a little bit my brother and I have a
sports agency and Ryan and I are
partners in this one 37 and every year
at the Super Bowl we're throwing up
[ __ ] the [ __ ] a bet
I don't know if you know this but we
have yg come through with yeah I mean a
little key to kid I just put you in Mt
grizzly and we [ __ ] wanted
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
why'd you kill why'd you something
normally the way I taught my brother
who's 11 years younger me to be an
entrepreneur was we would go to garage
sales by [ __ ] come home and flip on eBay
when eBay was early and make real money
and then one of the top 50 all-time
flips for us was we went somewhere and
they had like 500 Jet magazine and we
bought it for 10 bucks and when we took
it home to start looking up the Muhammad
Ali the Michael Jackson they were like
30 to 50 a piece we made like two three
thousand on the 10 bucks Jet magazine
that's the [ __ ] I want to buy it like I
would buy today Jet magazine and make it
a website and make it hot again and she
doesn't eight I owned Rick Ross young
jock I own great calm I owned
everybody's up
I at one time owned Kanye West dr. hill
group you'll appreciate down you'll
appreciate this
every time somebody hit me up I gave it
to him I own Rick Ross calm I own Kanye
West calm I own yo Josh calm I don't
[ __ ] everything cuz nobody knew I did
in the wine business like ten years
earlier like all the big wines I came as
silver oak but I never wanted to make I
never wanted to do the wrong thing so
like literally Kanye's lawyers said how
much we want for Kanye and I literally
uh I've applied in a minute zero
what's your IP address the reason you're
gonna win is you wouldn't do something
with something you didn't believe in
thus you're set but the requirement is
to listen to other [ __ ] to see what
serendipitously hits you in the heart
because authentic artists [ __ ] with
other authentic artists Tony Bennett and
Lady Gaga worked because they're the
same person
now it's about finding the EDM country
pop hey pop you want to really take it
to wanna be you want to be an
entrepreneur listen to every kpop fan
until you find one you [ __ ] with you'll
make 50 million in Asia I keep telling
people I'm not telling you to do some
[ __ ] like Milli Vanilli I'm telling
you to open up your [ __ ] mind listen
to everything that isn't in your genre
and the first time you're working out
vibe and smoking and you hear something
you're like oh that that's what you
doing and then use [ __ ] siphon
audience man if I was if I was you know
the same [ __ ] I'm doing with business if
I actually had this talent I would 24/7
listen to kpop find the first thing I
[ __ ] with and fly to South Korea and go
in the studio and produce and make a
hundo in Asia the next year hell are you
here I'm leaving Sunday believe your
inner peace lectricity and they are and
when you place
three they want a piece guys know about
the [ __ ] legend
Google is here your [ __ ] homework if
you don't know that's actually good luck
we had to bring it up real time real
pros for a minute
tomboy talent 4137 parties brains first
kickoff to NBA all-star go back you get
some sleep
sleeps important for the entrepreneurs
everybody's going to go to Jordan party
I'm not gonna Jordan party [ __ ] Michael
Jordan I'm a real next
[Music]
[Music]
Hey
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah no I'm gonna polish everything
later beside us
and they uh
[Music]
[Music]